this Madilyn Bailey thank you so much
for being here thank you for having me
welcome to camp et we have drinks we
have snacks we have coloring borrowing
books yeah it so excited about those are
I mean dive right in yes let's dive
right in yes VidCon you've been here a
couple times now anything you're
particularly excited for this weekend so
all month I've been auditioning and
rehearsing with my band and so tonight
actually is my first performance with
them oh my god I'm really excited yeah I
feel like you just lit up when you said
okay it's gonna be all my originals that
are we gonna be coming off my upcoming
album and so pumped well and I think
today's a big day for you because it
just went up for people today yes I went
for pre-order today what's the vibe of
the album the vibe of the album is I've
been saying if SIA was a young enough
up-and-coming artist that's what my
album would come up I do want to talk a
little bit just cuz we're in our
summercamp vibe about yes summer do you
have a favorite summer memory what was
like the best summer of your life did
you ever go to summer camp as a kid I
didn't but I I I grew up with a lot of
siblings so when summer started to when
summer ended we had it all planned out I
mean I remember my favorite summer
experience was when we went inner tubing
down the little river by our house and
we were gone all day long we were
actually gone so long that my parents
got worried and then around here yeah
and they drove down to the end of the
river and walked up it to find us there
because they were like they were
convinced that we had you know something
terrible had happened but what our
musical idols of yours who do you really
look up to I honestly I really look up
to Meghan Trainor and Katy Perry they're
both like total badasses in this in this
industry they not only write write their
own music and and our amazing performers
and singers but they also run their own
businesses with such dedication and
ethics and it's amazing well thank you
so much for being here with us so why is
there's not for pre-order right yes
pre-order on itunes go pick it up
amazing thank you Miss Madilyn Bailey
let me show you from here